liftoff from a tropical rainforest to
the edge of time itself
james webb begins a voyage back to the
birth of the universe
james webb has over 300 separate
deployments that have to happen and all
of them have to go essentially
flawlessly for the telescope to function
at all from the deployment of the high
gate antenna which should happen in the
next day or two the sun shield and the
telescope itself so all of those
gold-plated mirrors it's going to let us
see things that are up to a hundred
times dimmer than anything hubble was
able to see
about 10 times more clarity than things
we could see with hubble and we're
looking at things in a different
wavelength so hubble took a lot of
images in the visible wavelength range
and a little bit beyond that but we're
actually focusing on the infrared with
james webb so that lets us see different
types of features that we couldn't
necessarily resolve with hubble before
and we're going to be able to see back
in time so to speak even further all the
way back to about 13.6 billion years
into the history of the universe which
is a huge deal because we think the
universe is only 13.8 billion years old
so this gives us a chance to see the
universe right after it was forming
those really early stages